台股怎麼會這樣子
今天上漲了439點
大家覺得台股希望來了
但是他是開高走低
原本漲7 800點
今天三大重點來了
台股量能回歸了 量出來了
怎麼還會開高走低
我倆沒有明天嗎
第二個 Fed年底要升息
升息完了
哲哲你講對了
你告訴我們確定升息後
還有可能 有機會利空出盡
今天果然漲了
但是年底還要再升息怎麼辦
而且年底升息的機率很高
會崩嗎
今天雖然漲了
但是有點開高走低
上櫃指數是翻黑的 怎麼會這樣子
可是第三個 哲哲你講的也真的是對的
還有人說AI可以加速新藥研發
能重壓生技股嗎
你會發現到哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
郭哲榮分析師
也是全台灣唯一100萬粉絲訂閱
不只 140萬粉絲訂閱的分析師
僅此一位 好不好
大家好
如果你不認識哲哲
你一定是股市菜鳥
來 今天來看一下
今天大家換個新的不一樣的衣服 領帶
應該有穿過 我不確定
新的氣象
因為結算見轉折
怎麼這樣 哲哲
結算見轉折怎麼開高走低
怎麼會這樣子呢
我跟你講 因為現在大戶
我兩沒有明天
你看像信昌電
我當沖完以後就直接殺下去
最後一盤拉起來
國巨看起來今天本來要漲的
結果變成悲劇
本來以為是喜劇
哲哲 國巨到底要死不活
你看這一個月根本沒動
從那一天
我買台灣50那一天有沒有
我們放大 對 很好
買台灣50那一天對不對
後來隔了一天以後對不對
跳空大漲漲停板有沒有
我賺1000多萬
一天就賺1000多萬那一天以後
基本上股價就是要死不活
根本在一個Range裡面沒動
漲停板過後
這邊漲停板沒錯吧
這邊漲停板 要死不活
怎麼會這樣
第一個我覺得 我還是說
上面第一個 孤魂野鬼太多
第二個 很多舊雨新知
也參與這一波
等他們那些比較浮動的人
離開股市會比較好
為什麼說浮動的人
最近我發現一個東西 來
我先不講
我跟別家分析師不一樣
我今天可以講很多時間 來
講精材
今天股價收紅對不對
今天收紅嘛
講5347世界先進
我跟大家講
我覺得今天是一個照妖鏡
這一個月的台股是照妖鏡
就是如果你認為
分析師應該天天漲停板
用胡扯的 用騙的
請你不要看我的節目
我絕對不會去給你騙這些東西
因為我不認為分析師可以天天漲停板
你相信他天天都可以賺錢的
你被騙剛好
因為你相信嘛 你懂不懂
我是不可能被詐騙集團騙的
只要有人跟我說免費的
我都基本上不理他
我是跟大家講
所以我覺得 我要講的是說
這一波行情為什麼起不來
還有部份
不是怪你們
是很多的散戶
有一些新的散戶進來
因為你要想想看
去年成交量跟今年成交量
是不是差很多
現在啦 動輒今天多少
今天8000多億
以前去年之前你們看一下
這邊多少億
去年這邊 對不起 畫太多線了
以前連1兆都沒有
各位投資朋友
以前的去年的時候有沒有
2025年有沒有
動輒是5000億不到 有沒有看到
去年這個時候5000億不到
有沒有
去年這個時候 你看9月的時候
4000到6000億有沒有看到
現在呢
不到1兆唉唉叫
所以我告訴你 成交量增加了
除了股票市值增加以外
成交量增加 成交金額增加
可是也多了很多小白
以前沒在做股票的
那這些小白他就會
不能怪你們 我再強調不是怪你們
他經不起浮動
我最近發現很多會員
或非會員朋友
像昨天就有一個美女
哲哲我的國巨賠錢 還我錢錢
我不知道這個美女介不介意
應該不介意啦
介意你跟我講一下
我跟你Say sorry
你怎麼不說國巨了
把錢還我 我不玩了
這個是美女 應該不介意
我就直接嗆他
我每天都有講 賺錢你會說謝謝嗎
他就說我請你吃個飯
大美女 來
然後我就說
我不讓女生出錢的啦
我就跟他講
我說你注意一下
我看你國巨賠不到10%就受不了
這樣你可能比較適合買台灣50
注意我講的重點
這也是我要跟大家講
大概至少可能有5%到10%
我覺得你不一定適合股票市場
分析師講這種話
真的我講這種話
因為這個也是國巨現在漲不了的原因
因為大家受不了
等到賺錢他就馬上跑掉
那當然有賣壓
真的 我講真的
我不是怪誰 我講真的
因為多了太多小白
多了太多以前沒在做股票的人
或者有做ETF去做股票的人
這個他們是浮動的心態
那籌碼面看不出來
真的以前很少
我參加的會員很少
就是賠個5% 6%就不行
為什麼我說他
你看我跟那個美女講
我看你國巨賠不到10%
就受不了了
你可能比較適合買台灣50
不要來怪哲哲
尤其這個應該不是會員
不是會員哲哲覺得更扯
來 我今天不知道批誰
那位美女我也不知道批鬥你
我是要告訴你真的心態要改
你看這是他秀的對帳單
他自己在節目上秀的
他的國巨有沒有看到
570元買
今天國巨多少錢
看一下喔
529 今天又更低一點點好不好
本來今天有一度大概537嘛 不管
他目前為止大概賠7%
一檔股票賠7% 你受不了
一堆人國巨買1200
你叫其他人情何以堪
賠7%你就哭天搶地
哲哲對不起你了
真的 那你不是我的Target
你不是我的觀眾群
你或許也不適合當我的會員
我知道我的業務聽了會跳腳
但是哲哲也不缺錢
我是要告訴你
我也不是要趕你走
你這樣的心態不對
真的不對
我也不是要噹你
我知道有些人這樣賠錢受不了
不是啦
你要知道哲哲為什麼賺那麼多錢
因為我講賺那麼多錢
你不要覺得是因為我現在當分析師
沒有 我出社會的時候一毛錢都沒有
我也跟你講
跟我爸爸借錢還要生利息
我後來就不跟他借了
講這個我雖然也有點難過
但是我現在還是有養我爸爸
你不用擔心 好不好
我還是給他一個房子住
蠻大間的
所以我應該還算孝順 扯遠了
應該啦
因為孝不孝順不是我決定
是我爸媽認定我
我那時候是身無分文 沒錢
為什麼我可以賺那麼多錢
經得起波動
你們一定要記得一句話
這個行情很無聊
越無聊你越要看我的節目 懂嗎
才能度過那個波動
可是你不能 你每天去嚇自己
我有些會員每天嚇自己
或有些粉絲嚇自己
這樣忍不住啦
不要嚇自己啦
懂不懂 不要嚇自己啦
不要看那些網路負面新聞
也不需要看網路負面我的新聞
有一堆會員賺錢
今年一堆賺100% 賺200%
賺幾千萬的
你覺得賺2000萬的
導播你覺得賺幾千萬的
賺幾千萬的會在網路上PO新聞嗎
說哲哲讓你賺錢嗎 沒錯
不會嘛
所以一定有些是
負面的一定大於正面的
可是還是很多人喜歡我
都不用去看那些
重點是
國巨我是
我買都是買在500元以下
你們真的一檔股票
不要看十幾萬
看十幾萬你會難過
不要看數字 看%數就好
真的 看十幾萬
我出國可以幾次
幹嘛這樣想呢
而且最好玩的是
這個還不是我會員
所以你們如果波動那麼小受不了
不要看節目了
我是為你們好 我不是噹你們
不好意思
我是要告訴你
為什麼不要看節目
也不要做股票
你也不要參加別的
你參加那種漲停板的老師你會氣死
你會被騙更凶
我有很多 我以前很多都這種會員
去人家受傷
哲哲你講的都是對的
可是我還是受不了
參加那種漲停板的老師
可是再回頭已經百年身了
為什麼 我沒錢啊
以前我有錢參加你的會員
參加高等級會員的
現在沒錢了
就這麼慘了
你們怎麼會相信那種
天天賺錢的老師
那為什麼 照你這樣講
他應該百萬粉絲才對啊
怎麼是我
對不對
他可以天天賺錢
你們簡單的邏輯就好
所以被騙剛好
股市可以天天漲停板 被騙剛好
所以股市既然不能天天漲停板
你要忍受它
享受它 Enjoy它
今天現在考的是心態
就是因為心態現在不對
所以很多大戶心態也緊張啊
他看到散戶在殺殺殺
那我們選對的標的嘛
你要聽清楚
我剛才講的那些東西
從頭到尾都是心態
心態對了沒問題
你看今年漲了5 60%
今年台灣股市漲了5 60%
以前平均一年漲個10幾%
助理給我那個
我現在的漲幾%的圖
現在今年漲50幾%
他已經超標了
就算今年年底是收這個價格
他還是超標
只是沒達到我要的5萬點
是超級超標
外資以前幾年前沒有AI的時候
沒有疫情的時候
比大盤多個2%就厲害了 是不是
差個2%就厲害
所以你要記得我說的這個東西好不好
我是為大家好 OK嗎
所以今天先把心態搞對了
你就有機會賺大錢 好不好
來 我們看一下大家
希望大家學到東西
真的你看股票不要看那個什麼
10%受不了真的不要好不好 OK嗎
很無聊
可以敲桌子 大力一點
我今天不會敲大力
因為我今天有些股票開高走低
我大力一定是我有所本
賺得很開心 好不好 OK嗎
郭爸爸真是高招
逼我不得不成功是不是
看你們怎麼想 來啦
我是覺得人不要抱怨
比如說抱怨老天 抱怨這東西
助理我們再給一個圖
我那時候看一張圖就是
我忘記那個數字
就是薪資成長這幾十年來
只成長10倍
但是你投資股票
你可以成長1000倍
就差那麼多
所以你們有時候
怪老闆賺錢不賺錢 人性啊
真的不是每個人像摩爾這樣
這麼敢給錢
我後來發現
有時候跟一些老闆打交道
跟怎麼樣
不是會員的
我發現老闆很多想法
他覺得成功都是他的
我並不會這樣想
我會覺得我自己成功
我自己占很大的努力
但是我覺得老天爺幫我很多忙
可是大部分人不是這樣想
所以你沒有辦法去改變
那些老闆的思維
從薪水裡面賺很多 很多 很多
除非你超級有價值
可是股市不一樣
股市你就是自己的老闆
所以投資是需要的
我也很開心
我覺得我現在有改變這個市場
因為我們今天最近
就有一些銀行來找我們
那個摩爾的錢可不可以搞定存
據我所知怎麼樣
現在很多人真的去解定存
投資股市
所以這也是代表股市
會源源不絕有支撐的力量
真的
我就說傻了才去把錢放在銀行
我再講100萬遍都是
你只要記得我這句話
我為什麼出這本書
這個哲哲塞牙縫都不夠
你不要說我賺個20萬
我寫個書要寫個1 2年
賺個2 30萬那沒有用
我還分不知道幾十%給助理 忘記了
因為他要幫我校稿
幫我寫一些東西
但思想一定是我的
我不可能完全給人家代筆這種東西
你說有人幫我潤稿
那是需要
我花好多時間
可是我重點是什麼
不是為了稿費
那對我來說
我去收會員比較快
去買台灣50比較快
我要給大家一個觀念
你把ETF當作什麼
定存 活存
活存 還不像定存
需要錢再賣
現在我看到
什麼定存存下去
有沒有搞錯啊
之前定存我忘記多少%
1%不到
我隨便一檔ETF
都可以賺5 60%對不對
哲哲怎麼知道大家聽到度估了
修身養性 好不好
7%一天一根漲停板不就回來
還真的很多粉絲受不了
然後開始怪哲哲 對啊
現在量不夠
真的量不夠沒辦法
量不夠就是血液不夠
循環不夠 是不是
你看我今天
很多我都預告在前面
是不是 人生的心理面 醫療面
最近不是有陳建州 黑人嘛
小S的好朋友 很有名
以前是SBL是不是
忘記是不是職籃的
現在是職籃的創辦人
很多人都說身體那麼好
怎麼會這樣子
我早就說過
膽固醇跟你的身體好不好沒有關係
你70%以上膽固醇
就是身體自然而然產生的
膽固醇跟你的吃東西沒有關係
你吃得再怎麼清淡
運動都沒有用
我有親戚運動 運動
為了降高血壓 為了降膽固醇
每天運動
那都沒有辦法阻止你中風
你就是得要吃藥
有高就得吃
膽固醇越低越好
你記得我這句話
膽固醇越低越好 好不好
這個跟大家講
醫學小常識
今天講這些東西 人生心態
你看雖然人生心態
我也幫大家很多東西
來看一下 等一下
順便跟你講 等一下
等一下 我在看那個
因為我要解鎖
順便給你看一下 醫學小常識
等一下喔 等我一下喔
傳一下喔
就有人說陳建州
這個耳朵就不一樣了
什麼叫耳朵不一樣
可你看陳建州的耳朵
你們自己回去看一下耳朵
我後來看一看
我身邊蠻多人有這種耳朵
回去看一下
現在照鏡子看一下
你耳朵 老人家啦
50歲應該很明顯
有沒有 這有一痕有沒有看到
陳建州這邊耳朵也是凸起來了
有沒有 這耳朵有一痕有沒有看到
這一痕有沒有看到
好像一字起子畫下去有沒有看到
這耳朵有一痕有沒有看到
或一大塊的
這就是有可能要準備中風
為什麼
還有男生突然
硬不起來了
硬啦 硬啦
叫你All in就in
硬不起來
那也是中風前兆
哲哲會研究這些東西 為什麼
我是為你們著想
我這個健康
你如果用一分鐘來看
你覺得健康不重要
你用一天來看 你覺得健康不重要
你到你賺到錢
你要享受人生的時候
健康很重要
你懂不懂
就像氧氣一樣
每天有它你不珍惜
就像你爸媽一樣
每天有他你不珍惜
缺少了以後 很痛苦
健康很重要
就像我跟你講 股票也是一樣
你看一分一秒 看很短
我看的是很長
再講一次 哲哲有那麼短嗎
看很長
好不好 這個跟大家講
把醫療常識跟這個扯在一起
我也是很會扯
很多東西 你自己看
來 AI助攻新藥研發有沒有看到
他說怎麼樣
中國附醫院長
觀察藥物開發
他不用觀察 他看我的節目就好了
以往要花1 20年
現在可以縮短到幾個月
我早就講過了 好不好
藥物開發以往要1 20年
現在可以縮短到幾個月
有沒有看到
所以我就說
院長也好 醫生也好
會用AI的醫生
會淘汰不會用AI的醫生
會用AI的律師
會淘汰不會用AI的律師
會用AI的助理
會淘汰不會用AI的助理
你們一定要會用
相信我
這個我跟大家講
蛋白質運算怎麼樣
這個我都跟大家講了
講的話其實都是
你看 醫生講的有沒有
現在影響性
不是等差級數 而是等比級數
這個我也講過類似的話
而且講過90度的拐點
有沒有看到
已碰到治療天花板的疾病
都可能因為AI介入而突破新方向
中國醫藥大學的院長
講的跟哲哲這幾年講的
講了3年了差不多
不是說他不好 我不是笑他
而是我是預言家 不好意思
膽固醇這事我也是預言家
相信我十年後
大家會覺得
原來膽固醇藥越早吃越好
中風最痛苦
你走是一了百了
如果中風到一半怎麼辦
我不是嘲笑那些人
我是跟你講事實
我看比較遠而已
我都是為你們好
很多都是為你們好
有沒有看到我以後的趨勢
你知不知道我20年前
講ETF的時候
我是被投顧公司的副總老闆罵
你講什麼ETF 收不到會員
我管他的
我從來不在乎別人什麼看法
我也不管網路的負面什麼看法
我郭哲榮 我自己知道
我每天比我自己還嚴格看
比別人還嚴格看我自己
我不在乎
你們不敢想像20年前
不要說20年前
10年前講ETF也被人家笑 真的
現在每個人都說我是ETF專家
我買台灣50就好
他們有講得比我早嗎
我很敢講
你去問我身邊所有的朋友
不要說1 20年
20幾年來
我都不跟他報名牌
買台灣50就好
當然你們昨天有人講
不然就買台灣50
你也可以買
買台灣50績效比較好
No No No
如果你認為
今天我賺個5% 賠個5%
你就受不了的人
不論是會員或粉絲
你買台灣50你馬上也會賣掉
你相信我 你抱不久
真的 我今天跟你講人生的常識
好不好 OK
我對自己絕對很嚴格
怎麼都不嚴格
你看我家的身材就知道
我們都是易胖體質
我把自己身材變成這樣子
我超容易胖的
你們根本不知道
所以為什麼有時候跟你們開玩笑
推薦減肥針
我是那種
我是為了減肥可以那種
就是每天可以運動
逼自己運動3個小時
當分析師的時候
最後好不容易瘦了
又馬上反彈
因為我的食慾實在很難
有人說肥胖是一種基因 你知道嗎
因為我們特別容易胖
我之前有去測那個基因測試 北投
就是健檢中心
他說我是屬於肥胖體質
吃東西特別容易吸收
我說那不用做基因測試
還要我花十幾萬
我說我自己知道我容易肥胖
扯遠了
我是哲哲的麻吉 你們趕快按讚
不然我兄弟他要生氣了
不要每天生氣 這樣也不好
好不好 OK嗎
就是看哪一天我心情不好
我就直接不好意思先走了
看一集少一集 大家珍惜是真的
不過我很健康
哲哲是不是胖在我們看不到的地方
這句話我喜歡 沒有啦
我要生氣囉
哲哲知道血液淨化嗎
血液淨化我有查過 好像還好
血液淨化不如吃藥啦
因為你又不可能每天血液淨化
好像聽說有效啦 OK嗎
我看起來有這麼短嗎
哲哲是不是胖在我們看不到的地方
這不用重複了 知道就好
這個就回到我那一句話
就你All in就in
誰在酸我
有人酸我沒關係
我都祝福他啦
有沒有人酸我
嘉瑋老師我們也認識 也熟
酸不酸我都沒關係
他不一定酸我 我何必跳進去呢
不要太誇張的那種
其實同業喔 我不覺得嘉瑋
有人說做空的老師
嘉瑋老師酸不酸我
我其實 我跟你說真的
我覺得喔 因為年紀越大喔
我其實我也沒有很計較 大家也熟
他是不是酸我 我覺得不在乎
我祝福他 我也祝福他賺錢
為什麼不在乎
因為他不要是指名道姓的酸我
而且太誇張
我都不會很生氣 你懂嗎
你聽懂嗎 像之前那個張姓分析師
為什麼每次我要講他
他太誇張了
每一集都在罵 那時候每一集都在罵
罵整集幾十分鐘
導播我說的沒錯吧
害我出動很多人力
每天在看他在講什麼
所以你們真的不要攻擊哲哲
你們最後也累啦
真的也累啦
在法庭上我看他這麼累
我也覺得他好辛苦喔
他都記得他幾分幾秒講哪一句話
我們就直接跟他說
幾分幾秒你有攻擊我
你講話你要付出代價的
久了沒意思
不要那麼誇張我都不會生氣
我都祝福他們
所以哲哲容忍度蠻高的
所以不要讓哲哲受不了
要告 那真的是太誇張了
雖然嘴巴每天講講
我是屬於那個
面惡心善
好啦 說我自己善啦
至少我確定我不是壞人
好啦 扯遠了啦
讓我們來看一下
就是行情無聊
記得一件事 好不好
多開心 多睡覺 好不好
平常心 把睡眠治好 失眠治好
哲哲我會失眠 除非你很嚴重
通常今天失眠 明天會睡得好
不要想太多
今天失眠 明天失眠
後天會睡得好 好不好
可是就是你一直想多就睡不好
要接受自己的失敗
就像股票一樣
接受自己的一時不完美
好不好 我比你們還追求完美
你記得這句話
你們不開心 我比你們更不開心
只是我放在心上 好不好
可是我是跟你說真的
我今天不是批評那些人
你股票受不了波動
就買台灣50吧
可是如果你還是受不了
5% 10%受不了
那不要買股票 你去放定存
你這輩子沒有賺大錢的命
我是說真的啦
真的 所以你一定要改變你自己的想法
不論做股票或做ETF
那我們講一下新聞
所以AI助攻這個沒錯吧
有沒有 指數型嘛對不對
他說這個 這個東西不用講
這邊有做啦 有做簡介啦
等比級數的成長有沒有看到 來
那時候我有預告
不只等比 90度
助理有沒有90度的
沒有重播 有嗎
看一下助理有沒有給我重播
哈囉 助理 奇怪
叫他給我重播90度的 找不到
好吧 來
我們可能要再等他們一下
我們先看別的圖
來 我們看別的圖
等一下喔 來
兩位睡著了嗎
來 我們看一下
對 我看一下大家的反應
有時候你們的反應
有 這邊有
你看3年前喔
那時候15000不到
15000而已 16000不到
2023年
3年光是指數型ETF可以漲3倍
不就是要等
我問你一件事
你覺得現在台灣50
你感覺有動嗎
沒動對不對
可是其實我還是賺1000多萬
我講的是我7月底
7月底那一筆
7月29 30號那一筆
1000萬不是錢嗎
你感覺沒動 他其實有動
他動很慢
漲兩步 退一步
前進三步退兩步
他還是動
轉眼間那人已經在燈火闌珊處等你了
不好意思 他已經飛遠了
已經漲3倍了
3年前15000不到
現在45000以上
來看一下
我怎麼預告的來看一下
我都說了有機會17000以上了
為什麼我們行情高 而且AI的那個
AI的成長是指數型的成長
一般是線性型的這樣成長
他指數型是這樣子 90度的成長
拐點快到了 拐點快到
所以不論多或錯一切的一切預告在前面
到時候股市也會一個直線式的成長
為什麼
大家討論AI會毀滅人類
不代表AI進步很快嗎
不代表我說那個指數型的成長
數學上指數型就是這個意思
來看一下那個院長怎麼說
3年前 他現在才發現
我就跟你講我其實
最專業的醫學方面
我當然輸那些醫生
可是預測醫療方面的趨勢
或預測很多大方向趨勢
我比很多人強很多
你看這個
院長說的話
還大幅頭版新聞
大幅新聞有沒有看到
生技論壇有沒有看到 來
這邊 是哪邊
幾個月 指數型成長
這邊 有沒有看到
不是等差級數有沒有看到
是等比級數有沒有
不是等差級數
等差級數就是我剛講的
直線型的成長
不只 懂嗎
就是等比級數的成長有沒有看到
這邊講了
不只是等差級數有沒有
這慢慢跟大家講這些東西
看一下這邊
等比級數我找不到
沒關係 我這邊有寫
是等比級數的成長
是中國附醫院長講的話
你不要覺得這不可能
所以它是一個很完美的AI
不是 很完美的AI世界
2000年網路泡沫
也有人講說2000年網路泡沫
大家都不工作
現在年輕人都不工作了
昨天我看到台大政研社
網路上看到
我什麼都看
幾百人聽一場演講
當然演講的人很優秀也有差
然後 我什麼都看
要排隊 那又怎麼樣
重點是這個本身
現在的投資是不是泡沫
不是
因為以前進步不會這麼快
我再講一次以前進步不會這麼快
所以你們很幸福
為什麼講健康
因為到時候你們可能不健康沒有用
如果今天黑人
今天什麼意外走了
他有再多錢也沒有用
我不是噹他
我是希望大家
都要注意自己的身體
你懂嗎 我舉他的例子
因為他的例子你比較清楚
身材比我還好
比我高 比我壯
所以你們要把身體養好
可是你養好的前提呢
不要給自己那麼大的憂慮
把憂慮丟給我
我絕對是你看過
抗壓性最強的分析師
業界都知道
擊不垮我的
因為我知道我該賺的錢我賺
不該賺的我一毛錢不賺
我們分析師是這樣子
不該賺的不要賺
基本上我們就可以過得好好的
什麼意思
分析師很多搞到身敗名裂
就坑殺散戶 自己偷做股票
這些事我不去做
我也不會去強調過度的那個獲利
是不是
不要去做就好了
所以我跟你講 你不要參加就不參加
反而我這樣子賺比較多
所以抗壓性
你要把自己抗壓性
你每天很煩
賺到錢你也不健康
我已經講到心靈派的學說 為什麼
因為現在行情真的很無聊
可是行情無聊 我告訴你
可是巨大轉變你們不知道
黃仁勳在講這些
我希望你們做Agent
為什麼 每個人都做代理AI
為什麼黃仁勳叫你做代理AI
或者是AGI
因為你叫電腦越做越多事
只要做一次 做一次
Token越花越多
他就賺越多錢了
你就越需要它了 你懂嗎
你就想買他的晶片了
所以他很聰明叫你用這個
你看現在人也很變態
華邦電併英飛凌記憶體事業
全球NOR Flash
市佔突破3成
這是大利多 今天股票呢
沒漲 沒什麼漲
你們在開什麼玩笑
突然覺得國巨有點開高走低很正常
上櫃指數是這樣子
因為沒量
巧婦難為無米之炊
再怎麼厲害的家庭主婦或主夫
你沒有飯 你怎麼炊飯
你沒有飯怎麼煮飯
這是廢話 也是實話
沒有量怎麼搞
當沖 每個人想要隔日沖的
我倆沒有明天
所以我剛才前後呼應
來看一下
我倆沒有明天 所以開高走低
習慣就好
懂不懂 習慣就好
懂嗎
所以哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
我不去事後話 不去馬後炮
現在這個行情 來
撐住了 再講一次 年底
我剛才講中國附醫院長是什麼話
我是要告訴你
AI的發展無窮遠
你看 一個中國附醫院長講的話
他最近的發現
我3年前就講了
所以你要相信我
看3年後的台灣股市10萬點
我不敢說百分之百
我是合法分析師
我還是要跟大家講
我很不喜歡現在業界有個缺點
財經網紅 怎樣
我覺得除非你都完全不收錢
完全沒有任何利益
完全自己不會
你推薦什麼股票
你偷賣什麼股票
說老實話你不知道
你覺得他們會不會這樣做
我覺得很少人不會這樣做啦
跟你推薦這個股票
可能明天漲停了 可能就賣掉
可是我們是受監督的 懂嗎
雖然我們分析師受監督
還是有人不小心會偷做股票
被人家發現
用人頭戶
那你覺得那些財經網紅呢
我要跟你講的是說
我還是要跟你講
分析師還是怎麼樣
跟財經網紅差很多
光是我們的清白性
光是我們要考試
還要被監督就差很多
所以你可以不要參加分析師的
但是你也不要用
財經網紅的話來跟我們講 好不好
其實現在財經網紅很多東西
其實也可以問AI怎麼講 怎麼寫
差距不大
可是AI不能幫他考試
聽得懂嗎 我講的有沒有道理
AI不能幫他考試
現在台股的另外一個考試是什麼
能源危機
能源危機的考試 來
這個你來看一下
庫存偏低有沒有看到
截至2026年9月11號
美國戰略石油
你先看一下
原油價格一直漲
這幾天跌了對不對
因為川普好像下週要去中東國家
不是要去伊朗 是要去附近
沙烏地一定叫他不要打了
不然沙烏地會講什麼 叫他打嗎
叫他打早就打了
聽久了說不打了 他特地去
下禮拜特地去不是要聽這些話嗎
所以我還是認為 我重申一次
我認為川普就是孬
不好叫孬 中文文字不錯
他最後 為什麼敢講他
反正很多人批評他
第二個他聽不懂中文
他也不在乎我
他最後11月期中選舉之前
我生日之前會送給大家大禮
還是會談判
還是會 還是會 還是會談判
今天是幾月幾號 9月17號
記得 還是會談判 還是會和解
你不相信嗎 我唱首歌給你
導播太聰明了
來 原曲就好 3 2 1
還是會害怕
醒來不在你身邊的時候 害怕
從來不在你左右
或許我 還是會 還是會
還是會不知所措
好好聽喔 我的耳朵
沒事
講懷孕有點噁心
我不想對你有興趣
不是 他常常都吃我豆腐
明明我是投資長 會吃我豆腐
會碰一下我的身體
投資長要不要調整一下麥克風
好啦 跟他開玩笑
很好聽耶
你現在是不是真的不抽菸了
比較少抽菸了
戒了 戒了對不對
你看我很恐怖
我問你 我是不是第一次問
我有沒有抽菸都在節目上問
我很少問
導播那個喉嚨多乾淨
對不對 導播你也覺得
聲音變好聽對不對  對
你看聲音整個變好聽了
所以抽菸也會心肌梗塞這一種
都是一樣
可能導播聽到我講健康 健康
抽菸是最不需要的東西 你懂不懂
抽菸喝酒都該戒掉 真的不好意思
不會啦 其實現在台灣
全球世界抽菸的人口都下滑了
戒掉了 真的戒掉了 戒多久
你看你的聲音多好聽啊
27天
害我
你害我破防
沒有氣質罵那個
27天戒什麼菸啊 沒事
我想說3個月 27天
你可不可以等3個月再跟我講
我剛才 直播就是有這個缺點
可不可以把那一段剪掉
不剪也沒關係
沒有 我沒有講
沒有打字 沒有
戒27天
加油 可是27天OK
對不起 是他嚇到我了
對不起 我嚇到你們好不好 來
27天笑死
可你看他27天
他喉嚨真的變乾淨了
你們常常聽導播就知道
以前講話有痰的感覺
現在沒有了 好不好 OK
以前不想叫他導播 都叫他小痰
我剛才緊急公告一下
助理說川普沒有要去中東
是我看錯字了
可能我凌晨的時候
是中東領導人去紐約開會
可是我還是覺得川普
我絕對不敢說百分之百
我只是說還是會簽約
好不好 OK嗎
不然全球燃料危機
庫存已經偏低了
當然沒有耗盡 怎麼可能耗盡
運輸成本也增加了
因為繞很遠 好不好 OK嗎
核定容量7.14億桶
你有沒有看到
沙烏地阿拉伯這邊被攻擊了
紅海被攻擊了
以前他都會出口氣
現在不敢打他 有沒有看到
你有沒有看到第二件事情
黎巴嫩跟那個誰
那個美國總統好朋友叫什麼名字
都很愛打別人 叫什麼
那個 突然忘記了 你們都忘記了喔
你也忘記了喔
以色列 對
不好意思
節目上有時候真的會突然忘記那個詞
以色列 你們上去講就知道了
以色列的
以色列每天在打黎巴嫩
每天在用力打
OK嗎 這個跟大家講
看裝了N個心導管還在抽
戒菸看人的 什麼意思
裝了N個心導管還在抽
心導管真的很危險
人不開刀盡量不要開刀
不是說不尊重醫生專業
而是刀是醫生在開
但是身體是你的
盡量不要開刀
OK嗎 來
導播戒了吧
哲哲老闆每天忍耐你的菸味
他的菸味不重 好不好 OK
導播真的聲音挺好聽
聲音真的變好聽了 來
今天喇低賽
所以你看喔 這個大利多股市不會漲
三成耶 30%耶
你看喔 23加11大概34
不會 會有流失
還有什麼業務重疊
所以三成差不多
你看三成已經變最大
NOR Flash耶
都會缺啦 Flash
NOR Flash
NAND Flash都會缺你懂不懂
他重新引入這個Spansion的品牌
那個品牌有沒有看到 357億
我覺得買這個喔
我覺得英飛凌把它賣掉
也是蠻好玩的
會賺錢啦 好不好
所以這個NOR Flash
你看我們做這個圖都不錯 好不好
高容量NOR Flash
下半年估漲一倍
所以這個我覺得300多億不會貴啦 好不好
AI這個下半年要漲一倍 好不好
這張圖就做得比較差
這就是新進的分析師
還在培訓 有沒有看到
你看這個就做得很漂亮
所以你們要有美感 你們就看到
他還做5 6張
一般的分析師做的圖大概就這樣子
我們其他投顧
不是摩爾投顧的分析師
其他的分析師
真的大概 這樣就做得不錯了
我這張圖 他就被我唸5 6遍了
你就知道我們摩爾
訓練出來的分析師很嚴
這種圖被我唸5 6遍 我很變態
也是這個原因
我覺得我也不找主持人
說老實話 我覺得
所以我跟你講
我要求別人很嚴
但是我要求自己最嚴
這張圖不好看
你看 同樣的NOR Flash漲一倍
英飛凌
華邦電就是併購英飛凌的
NOR Flash這個東西
你看這張圖不就很漂亮
這才叫合格的圖
所以我絕對是全台灣最懂AI的
你懂不懂
我現在面試設計人員
我都跟他講你的圖怎麼做
怎麼下指令 重點是下指令
我不能教太多 教太多
因為別家投顧都會看我的節目
其實我每天都告訴他們很多事情
以前投顧界都愛亂罵人
真的 都攻擊來攻擊去
是我開始矯正了
這樣講你們會覺得噁心
是真的 以前很誇張
他們發現攻擊別人也沒有比較好
現在就不會這樣做了
發現講漲停板不如講一點總經
好像還可以收到會員 開始講總經了
以前他們不講總經的 不講台灣50的
我是跟你說真的 下面可以舉手
十幾年前的分析師是不講的
大家可以幫我作證嗎
有沒有老菸槍 不是老菸槍
愛看投顧節目看超過十年的
回應我一下 OK
哲哲夜盤開始噴了 本來就該噴了
但是我跟你講
我覺得台灣股市 世界股市
怎麼樣
萬事俱備 只欠東風
東風是誰
通膨下滑 噴出
就這樣子
AI它是持續會漲的 你相信我
通膨而已好不好 OK嗎
這個跟大家講
Fish下半年要缺 趕快去買 什麼意思
來 哲哲帶領潮流
27天也不錯
來 夜盤 我們看一下夜盤
200多點也不錯喔
4667張 其實現在正價差400點
這邊可以放大嗎 應該可以
有沒有剛好 不錯
46680是最新的期貨
這是今天的收盤價 45多少
46288跟46680 差不多400點
400點很多 正價差為什麼差400點
期貨為什麼比大盤多400點
一來現在漲233點
多了大概200點
另外本來就正價差200點
200點加200點就400點
這樣懂不懂 Understand
所以這不錯 夜盤在噴喔
趕快買 真的 相信我
我的旺宏越來越死怎麼辦
旺宏不是我 人不是我殺的
請問台灣生技股大有可為嗎
台灣生技股有可為
但是不一定要投資生技股
我不喜歡生技股
因為很多台灣的生技股純粹炒作
當然我支持政府投資生技股
炒作是一回事
本來就有泡沫的存在
只是我的會員先求不傷身 再求療效
OK嗎 買藥是這樣子的
先求不傷身 再求療效
懂不懂 股票也是這樣子
這個跟大家講
納坦雅胡 來
三期會員經驗
你看這個李先生 李久康
跟著哲哲只要穩住心態都可以賺大錢
真的網路上很多抱怨我的
都是做個一期或不到一期的
抱怨我很凶 真的啦
但是我不能說沒有那種
做比較長的抱怨
我會員太多了
會員不是幾千人而已 你懂不懂
可是你去想一件事
如果我真的那麼差
我會活到現在嗎
去想一下我講的對不對 OK 來
年底會5萬點
從頭到尾我們沒有改過
我們沒有改過年底5萬點這件事情
我不是年底5萬點
我怎麼敢破4萬的時候買
我跟你講 我1億 我賠錢
我不在乎賠錢
我在乎的是丟臉啊
你要了解我在乎的是丟臉啊
我1億賠錢丟臉死了
我到這個程度
我已經在乎的是丟臉
你記得這件事好不好
OK嗎 來 這個跟大家講
哲哲根本是股市心理醫生
越看股市身心越健康 真的
其實股市中長期向上
很多散戶為什麼股市
我聽我媽媽講我股市賠錢
胡扯啊 股市越漲越多怎麼會賠錢
為什麼
因為你看到賠錢你就受不了
看到賺錢你也受不了
看到賠錢馬上賣
你不就賠錢了嗎
不是說停損不好
是看到賠錢你馬上賣
然後看到
然後這檔股票可以賺一倍的 你也
賠錢了
他們最常賣的不是賠錢的時候賣
是賠錢以後馬上賺錢
我本來賠10萬
我一賺1萬塊我就走了
因為我很怕賠錢
可是我明明可以賺100萬的啊
我本來賠10萬就受不了
我現在只要一賺
賺1萬塊我好開心喔
我今天可以吃便當了
我可以吃好的
賺1萬塊就走了 對不對
明明可以賺100萬的
你就每天波動 波動
就是這樣 為什麼
他們就是這樣子
要下市的股票死不走
然後又集中投資它
越加碼越多
如果你一開始只買10%還不會怎麼樣
不是 分散投資 選對標的
就算真的萬一你很討厭停損
像我也不太喜歡停損
你很討厭停損
就算你真的買到一個
真的快要下市的股票
你有分散投資其實還是有機會賺回來
你還是要分5檔
你1檔股票就Out了 就下市了
80% 另外80%股票翻一倍就夠了
還是賺60%
我說的沒錯吧
很多股票這幾年是翻一倍
他們沒有分散投資
沒有抱很久
所以就覺得股票沒賺錢
懂我在說什麼
好 哲哲該回歸個股分析了 謝謝你
我剛才是心理醫生
現在來個股分析好不好 來
現在All in你會謝謝我 OK嗎
這個都來一次的 不理你
沒有每天看我節目的
不要問我問題 拜託
我從去年股災到現在
連續跟2年會員了
有沒有看到 你看會員講的
賺幾千萬有沒有看到
會員講的
所以真的要記得一件事好不好 來
0050理論上
因為我是 理論上不需要
買ETF真的不太需要
巴菲特都叫他太太
好像97%還是99%
去買S&P 500 ETF
那他會叫他停損嗎
你去問巴菲特
理論上
因為我們不能講百分之百
我只能說99%理論上是這樣子的
因為你停損什麼
你投資台灣
台灣前50大的公司你都覺得不好
可是前提是你不能融資
不然你也不得不停損
不過我講什麼事都不能鐵齒
要講理論上
來 我們看一下股票
今天講的股票很重要
來看一下 現在幾分
不好意思 今天講很多心理面
為什麼
因為今天很多人的問題
包含你急著叫我講個股
也是心理面
你在看
你在看我覺得好像我在亂講話
不是 我從頭到尾在講你心理面
很多人為什麼愛上我
很多人為什麼 我的點閱率那麼高
因為他們知道
其實要不是看我節目
他們撐不下去
你記得這件事
你現在還在看這個節目
這些股票都會噴出去
你要相信我
不論是院長講的話
跟我3年前講的有什麼差別
我3年前看到這些未來 3年前
我又不是醫學相關的人士
所以你現在相信我
我跟你講說疫情的時候
只有我說疫苗1年內可以產生
被好多人罵 被醫生打電話罵
你懂什麼
不好意思 我還真的懂一些些
你懂不懂
最專業的東西
最專業的術語我真的不懂
你們比我厲害
而且我跟你講
現在我還更懂 我有AI
我看了很多文獻
比很多醫生多
我看了很多法律見解
我現在在看法律的東西
當然他們還是很專業
我有閱讀障礙比較難一點
我也喜歡看
我用AI會查很多東西
當然要跟醫生比還是差
要跟律師比還是差
不好意思 你們有你們的專業
只是我跟你講說 我真的很喜歡
我很變態 我很喜歡蒐集新資訊
我覺得感覺很有成就感
好啦 喇低賽
最後幾分鐘來看一下 看一下股票
台勝科你看很多股票還是故意拉起來
所以你看不出來
你從台勝科看不出來要噴了嗎
台勝科最差就是走信昌電模式
就是拉台勝科 不拉環球晶
拉信昌電 不拉老大國巨
拉台勝科不拉老大
那個都是圍魏救趙
最後老大還是會噴出去 為什麼
老大不發威你當我病貓
是老虎是不是 沒有啦
老虎 老鼠傻傻分不清楚
好啦 OK
看一下台勝科 OK
這樣懂嗎
這個都是要拉起來的
矽晶圓也是要噴出去
我跟你講前幾天的矽晶圓說
明年要缺貨
缺貨的那個缺口越來越大
這都是大利多都不反應
遲早會反應
什麼時候反應
I don't know
可是有反應的時候我會跟你講
或我感覺要反應的時候
我會跟你講
所以那時候再參加我的會員
不好意思 你先少賺兩根
至少兩根漲停板
所以最好的方式還是參加我的會員
你自己來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我 好不好
點我們的LINE 點進去
要上面
我講得很清楚 每天再跟你講一下
這個一定要講一下
這個要講 這不是為了要收會員
是怕你被騙
來看一下
助理沒有喔
哈囉 這邊
助理以後這個要放在最前面
這個LINE 有沒有
沒有這個白勾勾
藍盾牌白勾勾
沒有這個盾牌白勾勾的
盾牌 外面是盾牌
裡面白勾勾
百分之百造假
這樣懂不懂 不用問我了
以後就是個 盾牌 白勾勾
叫你加LINE
以我這邊說的話為主
這個說話用圖片的 不要
圖片都可以截圖 你懂不懂
這個用圖片
這個也可以做出來 你知道嗎
不要
而是真的不是圖片的
而是LINE裡面講的話
這樣懂不懂 先跟你講
來看一下股票 來看一下
愛你們啊 我愛你們
微星
今天股票真的沒什麼好講
因為就沒量
微星也這樣殺下去
拉起來
可是你看現在真的
越漲越多 漲257點
誇張了 已經價差430點了
正價差 期貨比股票多430點
最後他們兩個會All in one
會合在一起 好不好
理論上會合在一起 好不好
來 或靠近 結算的時候靠近
國巨在這邊 來
2492華新科
今天又跌 怎麼看
華新科我覺得300元以下就是買
國巨600元以下就買
助理 來 為了表示我的證明
我明天新會員我要再買
華新科我要再買
好不好 這個跟大家講
2376 夭壽 沒在動
技嘉有 技嘉這個
技嘉先突破這個吧
先突破這邊吧
好不好 放大 先突破這邊
先突破這邊再說 好 來
最後我們來看一下 快速看股票
3374精材還是台股最強的股票啦
也是我們最強的股票啦
你看我們還擁有它 真厲害
來 我們來看一下 還有
世界先進
世界先進今天噴出去了
所以世界先進你看
世界先進說老實話
世界先進之前最牛皮
現在看起來要噴出去了
這種股票你說老實話
這個看起來比國巨更討厭 根本沒動
突然噴一根你怎麼知道
就放著 抱著吧
好不好
真的 相信我 你們每天看那個
短暫的2%3%
很急著要我解盤
你要我解沒關係 你心態要對
你心態不對
你相信我容易賠錢
你很容易賺一點點就走
然後賠賠大的
真的 散戶會賠錢就是很簡單
賺小賠大
賺都賺一點點就走 賠都賠大的
記得我這句話
今天說穿就這幾句話好不好
學會了你就會賺很多錢了好不好
OK嗎 這個今天跟大家講
看今天最後有什麼問題
加持華新科
哲哲是我看過最有勇氣的分析師
不會像其他分析師一堆問號
很多人都這樣子啊
不然天天漲停板 漲停板又有了
你們真的
我要我要導正投顧的惡習
天天漲停板你相信
你被騙剛好
如果漲停板了
他應該幾百萬粉絲訂閱了
這個你們相信
分析師本來就要預告在前面
好不好 OK嗎
賠不到10%你還受不了 做什麼股票
是真的啦
但是我不會用這種口氣 我是為你好
因為你賠10%你就受不了
你會賺小賠大
你賺小錢就會走了
到時候賠大的 OK嗎
聯電可以看一下嗎
好 你這種口氣我OK 來
老二哲學 握久了就會長大
你的老二哲學
怎麼感覺是18禁哲學 來
00981A還可以買嗎
00981A那時候叫你買的時候不買
我不理你
不要 我一律推薦台灣50
你看我很少推薦00981A
那時候跟你講 對不對
那時候買了都賺25% 30%
就是那時候破4萬點
來 我們看一下2303 幾分了
聯電很漂亮
你不講還好 我都想買了
這個線型怎麼那麼漂亮啊
聯電的線型我給他90分
謝謝你
所以你看我在做好事 幫你解股票
我也來幫我自己做好事
這不就是這樣子嗎
所以有時候不要去計較
一點點讓給人家
賠錢一點點讓給他
懂不懂 你不要計較那個賠了
你反而賺更多
股市也是一樣
好不好 今天是股市心理學
真的 因為看到好多散戶好緊張
你要記得為什麼我成功
為什麼我這些東西
不要去計較那麼多東西
當然心態要對啦
我也是修養出來的
以前人家攻擊我 我也是很氣
現在很正常 越來越正常
希望能維持 好不好
大家一起努力
股市記得 搞定你的心態就會賺大錢
等到你真的覺得
這個股票噴出去了
真的已經20%了
你不如現在先來找我
真的可能已經賺20% 賺10%以上
所以歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
要選就選最紅的分析師
你們家有沒有
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
也加我的LINE
私訊我說 哲哲我要賺大錢
我窮盡我的努力 我竭盡我的努力
來幫你賺大錢
謝謝各位